and we are live welcome to the last word
with ebon tees we got a special guest in
a building e do we do very happy to have
ya so we get a lot of stuff to talk
about today one little quick
introduction piece for me just as well
audio platform thank you guys who are
catching this on audio we are on iTunes
Spotify Google podcast in all the places
and the listens keep coming so thank you
guys very much and so keep tuning and
you can find it just search you montes
Lord talking your last word you'll find
us it's easy to find but in proper guest
fashion I'm gonna turn it back over to
Lord kognito for what he does best so
here we go let's go man so welcome to
the last word episode number 61 it's not
the glorious Friday and we're back in
front of the campfire for some ludus
shooter discussion I'm extremely excited
about a special guest so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord not the car we're gonna introduce
the Lord whose passion for Bungie in the
Destiny community is truly remarkable to
follow now is this law one of the
Masters of graphical visualization but
has the uncanny ability to showcase our
favorite layouts in a clear and concise
manner introducing the UX designer
specialist and everyone's favorite
destiny infographic dude the lord of
heroic public events and pure gamer at
heart
live from Minnesota and kind enough to
make his debut within the realm of tlw
mom made Lord nervous how you doing sir
man I'm excellent and even better after
that good to have you brother
that is amazing thank you thank you for
having me I'm glad to be especially
after what's what happened this week oh
this week has been absolutely nuts and
we have a bunch of stuff to talk about
but I just heard a little timer beep no
no that was my I know what that was okay
blaming me good that was the countdown
timer of the
of its starting so we are right on time
but yeah Nerissa
see if i can say that right keep it
thank you for joining us this morning so
how do people know you around the world
of destiny if they don't already which
they should if you've seen a weekly
infographic or a graphic that explains
how to do public events heroic
activations or a infographic that has a
ton of exotic catalysts on it basically
anything that was very easy to read and
present it visually well that had to do
with destiny I probably had something to
do with it
there are a lot of others that's not say
I'm the only you know one making
infographics out here there's a lot of
very tale to people making some very
awesome stuff but a year and a half ago
I just kind of decided that I wanted to
create some design help for destiny
because let's be honest they don't
explain every aspect of the game very
clearly so you know that that I just I
pump out stuff every week for for
everybody and lead up a discord for that
and Twitter and Facebook and patreon and
I knew where else it can really get it
up on gee forums nice nice yeah now I've
seen him before and we've chatted before
when weekly resets get thrown off we're
both going come on Bungie like you and I
both are like Oh kind of dependent on
those things yeah then it was the one
day we had like seven night falls I
remember that being an absolute mess
that was fun that was that stayed that
way for like an hour
yeah Moseley it's gonna be a fun week
lots of stuff today a lot of options and
then BAM you learn a lot there you you
learn to go for about a 10 minute window
and if it's if it hasn't changed from 12
to 12 10 I'm like I'm putting it out now
hmm yeah and then I know for cert yours
putting out a really good graphic of his
inventory and the roles and stuff like
that the big question we keep waiting on
is the random roles are they ever gonna
actually get their poster this Tuesday
yeah we will see so lots of things come
in so yeah I mean if you guys are here
for the world of destiny you are in the
right place this morning season of
opulence has just been throw
all over us this week we have two
different orders like just everything
constant like seasonal opulence and I'm
like I cannot like put all of this
together so we have the first article
come out and then we had the full page
of like the season info itself then we
had the table drop some more fancy
tidbits so we've got a lot of things so
we're gonna start with basically just
the May 28th just need em team article
about season of opulence if you guys
haven't seen the trailer please do so
shout out this morning guys as well if
you guys are doing follows I will try
and catch those at the end will shout
out all those towards the end but yeah
what do you guys think of even just the
trailer to get us started so far we
start off with trailer I like a first
thing that I really like and stood out
to me and they commented on is that
they're not gonna do if I die for this
one so I really like that we have 56
seconds of everything - Ajay just kind
in a way before all of the content hits
and we haven't had that since I don't
know I mean even forsake and put out a
ton of what some would call spoilers you
know I've that's that stood out to me
number one and and other than that I
love the look the environment I can't
wait to get in there and explore we'll
get into details on the other trying to
space space in it I know
ya know overall video is great I really
like just that it's a small just a small
segment and the rest is left up to our
imagination to figure out what we're
gonna get until Tuesday nice little dog
neato sir yeah very excited um trailer
definitely was effective oh my like the
aesthetic you know I'm what I think much
is I'm not gonna say live I didn't like
my top braid it's not a battery but I'm
just saying like that probably my top
three but you can't deny the aesthetic
like it's really cool like it's a very
you know opulent here's they're kind of
big and you kind of appreciate the
colors the golds and your purples and
all that stuff so in from Minnesota
Golden Purple's my [ __ ] they're biking I
there's a viking talking
so I know you appreciate it but yeah
it's just a cool concept and you get to
see I will dive deeper you know the
things that they bring in into the
seasoning activities and stuff and I'm
not gonna like you know we talked before
II you know about man
coming into opulence and I had a little
bit of excitement in the trailer
definitely warranted some excitement so
I'm like all right let's see what just
dive into this bad boy we see what's
about yeah you guys pretty much covered
it I like how it didn't give too much
again it's just kind of a tease of
what's coming so I really like how they
it's not quite the season of history
anymore it's not everything as the world
of redacted but they haven't as you said
for forsaken and we knew like almost
every exotic that was coming I'm like
don't I mean people have already picked
apart the trailer enough so like people
have done that anything if you look deep
people have seen some things that are
coming but honestly I like how they they
tried not to give too much they gave the
proper amount of tees but they didn't
throw everything at us which is nice
I'm but I'm curious to go back and and
sort of compare it with the other
trailers now that we know activision is
and then the in the picture anymore to
see if that was an outsourced thing the
way they used to cut trailers because
thinking of it off top my head like like
the other trailers probably and this
just could be to the amount of detail in
them as well but those things were like
movie trailers in a way versus this one
was very small Joe what would probably
you know just be some freecam gameplay
stuff right I don't know understood I
should do that and go back to parents
yeah it's a good boy it's good boy what
I would give for a free camera photo
mode in this game I swear oh man all
right
there's so many times I'm like alright
let me jump up in the air switch weapons
hit my screenshot button I'm just like
that's how I have to have a screen shot
since I'm little mess so give me give me
a no gun just display just a photo mode
for a second you know what I'll even go
look at Dolan Karim in the face I can
just get a good security but yeah the
next thing we saw was the Forsaken
calendar so they said this is everything
that has been introduced in season the
forge season director and what we will
see in season um of the office of of
opulence so we've got kind of a bit more
detail now as to what is coming so we
know the last two seasons
whether you've liked them or not how
it's been coming and things like that I
I do want to say first off that this is
probably the most amount of content
we've ever had like between droughts and
things like that from forsake him there
was no taking king drought afterwards
before rise of iron we have had stuff to
do now some people have not liked the
way it's been delivered some people have
had their ups and downs with you know
gambit being very specific to a mode but
they have continued to give us little
pieces here and nuggets of things as
opposed to just this big drop which I do
have to kind of give them a shout out
for cuz when you look over this entire
basically past nine months of what we're
gonna have total for the annual pass in
my mind it's like totally worth it for
everything they put in the game for like
30 35 bucks there's no question to me
that I think it's if you enjoy destiny I
think it has been a really great thing
that they've done yeah that's the caveat
right there's what did you expect for
$30 like you you did base stuffs already
there it's for the people who want to
put in the extra time spend the extra 30
and and you have a whole lot of extra
stuff to do yep so for season of
opulence I don't know if you're gonna
read this thing left or right but we'll
kind of go that way
so for your free seasonal updates the
basic stuff that we've got as usual
power increases vanity rewards rank
Awards triumphs lore books iron banner
all that stuff's normal we have an
exotic quest for everyone we don't know
which of the two that we have listed so
far it's gonna be we'll get to that in a
little bit and we have solstice of
heroes will cover a bit later just as
last year before Forsaken now the new
stuff we've got we've got the raid we
know about that crown of sorrow launches
on the 4th everybody's been doing their
crazy raid prep six hour grind I know
we'll get there later but that emblem is
calling to me for the first 24 hours it
looks happy it looks damn good I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to do it but
now looking at that emblem I really
wanted just I wanna believe it there it
looks really really awesome from
everything else we know one more exotic
quest some lore books the penumbral
chalice which I think as the chalice
will get deep into but the big thing is
the menagerie so I want to send it off
to first near NARAS I'm gonna ruin that
all day in my head I said there's no
but the menagerie from what you've seen
just kind of a brief overview what what
are you feeling about this so far we got
a little deep deep discussion coming up
when we get to table yeah I am I'm
feeling really good about the the the
shoes part the details obviously at face
value a six-person match made activity I
am skeptical about somewhat just given
how the reckoning has gone transfer
that's for but I don't know we don't
know much else like what you know other
than screenshots and then what it looks
like it looks like it could have some of
the the rate encounters that we had in
spire and stuff like that like I'm
seeing a lot of relics or art balls or
whatever it is going on there so I you
know I guess I'm excited to do something
that has the potential to be another you
know waved a tiered activity with with
guardians and and the chance to get
armor and and weapons and stuff that I
choose out of that that's gonna be
really fun absolutely I'm looking I'm
very much looking forward to it but I'm
keeping my expectation it's very real
that's good I mean honestly the way this
whole seasons have been that's probably
a good thing to do mister Cognito
thoughts on bananas so far just general
high-level thoughts
I'm excited oh I'm a huge fan of um
escalation protocol and my only Achilles
heel to it was the fact they had no
matchmaking and we had to do all these
tricks and you know with blueberries and
tell your friend to tell my friend and
let's up stuff just to get is so like
I'm excited you know it'll be
interesting to see how mechanic heavy it
is and um you know we shall see so I
mean I think like looks similar when
iris was saying like I've seen bits and
pieces of like Leviathan raid encounters
almost felt like I saw um did the
gauntlet at some point and some things
that add little shades of it so I'm very
interested to see what part of the
Leviathan this is a section Department
to be of the fight that we had but uh
not seriously it does look
a new space it looks big I'm excited
about it and um you know it's just gonna
be curious to see how but can it can be
it is but I do like the fact that
eventually it's gonna be a heroic mode I
believe right and then then there is
like a part where they like no you have
to match week so low point good point of
entry and we'll see how it advances yeah
but I mean in looking at the pictures it
seems like there's I mean there's like a
triangular shield wall I'm kind of
wondering if there's like a big open
area and like if you have to knock out
bosses to go around and eventually
there's because there's one picture in
screenshot where there's a big hole in
the ceiling and that looks like this
large circular room where there's a lot
of fighting going on I don't know if you
like have to clear an upper level and
then everybody jumps down in to clear
out a final encounter below but yeah a
lot of speculation as to how the
encounter is gonna go I saw the people
running with balls but all in all it
seems like they say couple things they
say kind of a random pathing basically
like whether it's gonna have some
randomness to it I'm curious to what
level linking how much is it like go to
the left and fight the high ever go to
the right and fight the foam like how
much is it actually gonna be random who
knows or is it like truly gonna have
some actual differences to each run that
you do so the randomness is what I'm
really curious about mostly to see the
replayability because that's one thing
they actually mentioned it here and if
they throw it up I never quite know it
but as Nayar said it's like temper those
expectations because I can only expect
so much yeah but you brought a good
point up because we've got the menagerie
that starts and we've got PowerSearch
bounties we've got all of that stuff
coming and the menagerie and kind of
start both start on the forth so for
your calendar specifically for season of
opulence June 4th is when everything
kicks off and mostly when everybody's
gonna go bonkers because the raid race
begins June 4th six hours after so it's
gonna start at like 6 p.m. so I have no
idea what my sleep schedule is gonna be
like it's a mess no that's gonna be a
nightmare
but menagerie is going to be going
active at the same time so we've got a
quest that everyone has to do it's gonna
be kind of your invitation to the season
of opulence it's gonna be how you kind
of start crafting your child's that
you're going to use for all this stuff
and that's the one that everybody kind
of wondered
how long it's gonna be so as that's the
first thing we're gonna do in season of
opulence what do you guys expect for a
length of this quest what do you think
we're gonna do is it just gonna be like
hey Calais come back do two things go do
you guys think it's actually gonna be
like as we were talking last week I know
we were sub wondering if there was gonna
be any connection so deniers what do you
think what do you expect out of this
quest much not much well did anybody see
Giggs talking to Dylan
he what he wants to know big a brain
crab and and and don't said play the
game
so I just given the answer I think it's
not gonna be very lengthy at all I think
it's gonna be very very much akin to our
synthesizer with mm-hmm
grifter there it'll be probably here's
your chalice go run one and and then see
Benedict and and he'll do something that
drops a pass you know what I mean and
imitate I don't know I don't know but
that's just what I see because then it
then it Forks it you know at that point
then you have your thing for menagerie
and then oh what is this that I just got
for completing one that I can go now do
you know the bigot is gonna be a
cinematic story attached I'm not
expecting one I would be very pleased if
we did but I am I'm not gonna put that
expectation in my head ludo after black
armory and and drifty
hey enough enough yeah we got two
cinematics in drifty we got one in the
beginning and then one eight weeks or I
guess nine weeks later with a little
break in the middle so we got a little
bit with those but it was you know not
what I hoped for I mean it was better
than it's better than black armory cuz
while ADA actually had probably an
interesting like lore behind her we
didn't get much of it at all which is
kind of unfortunate especially when you
went through and did the final puzzle it
was like you got a little bit and I was
like but I want more and we got squat so
yeah it would be nice to get a little
bit more their biggest thing I'm going
for since this is a new raid for them to
actually show that maybe they can
connect somehow this quest to the raid a
little bit of just story connection even
if it's like a decent voiceover line
some type of connection is all I want be
like hey here's the chalice you gotta go
craft
from these pieces on these planets put
it together okay Calais gives you this
little voice over line be like alright
you have been summoned to you know the
lower Leviathan or whatever so that's
what I want to see don't know if it's
gonna happen I'm proud I'm proud of you
where you requested digs I like that
it's not just random thing knows I'm a
paying I hope completely geez yeah the
one adventure that if you skipped you
have no idea why we're going to little
more exactly why were in the shiny ship
of gold yo yeah like what's the fervor
exact now I'm would you man I think if
they again some type of context some
type of narrative like it's images of
voice even it's like when you started
the last witch raid and you know Pecha
was talking it you know just have Calais
talking about getting fat from strength
or something you know something and just
you know just tired and really cool and
I mean I it is promising that there is a
quest before you can even do the raid so
one could be hopeful there's some even
if it's text something you know I'm
saying just I this whole thing in
together
indeed and then I don't know if you guys
I've seen the picture floating around of
basically the big gold barge that's
gonna float in yes OSS yeah that picture
that I've got is huge that was the one
you and I were looking at actually bags
that's massive so yeah that's a giant
picture they felt like rendering out
there so that is gonna have some
probably part of the quest and either
your connection to it so here's the same
but as they state Calais would see you
grow stronger through the chalice of
opulence which serves as a Guardians
gateway to treasure in season of
opulence players who best the menagerie
and new six player match main activity
will use the chalice to create an
offering of runes which we will
definitely get into in exchange for the
specific weapons and armor they seek and
you kind of touched on that earlier I
want to stop right there and we didn't
quite have the table when this first
came out what did you guys have in mind
for how when it says like specific
weapons and armor how did you guys think
that was gonna go because now we've got
a bit more detail but when you first saw
this what did you what did you expect
I tried not to I mean I just the first
thing I just thought of choice I was
like okay they really trying to promote
choice as opposed to you know how
painful orangy was that's been a big
complaint with seizing a drifter right
like we can't you know get specifically
what we want stopped oh I thought it's a
step in the right direction I mean
that's literally you know I still look
at the challenge almost like the
synthesizer in some respect with the
upgrading and stuff like that but um I
think this is a new direction I think
this is them trying to listen to give us
a little choice that's literally what I
thought when I heard yeah no I mean we
know a little bit more and we will get
into that trying to keep this in real
time
I mean first for I thought um I tried
not to and then I'd set my worst
expectation was which would have been
the what we had in Osiris with what we
thought was going to be forging and was
not at all yeah so I set that at my very
you know base line of like okay if if
this is what they're referring to then
okay here's the worst that we've had
this at so it can't be any worse than
that
you know and then looking forward to the
other items that we've had like the the
oven which had different combinations
and things to spit out something and
then the synthesizer now with the three
other the one where do you do two
specifically not necessarily which piece
of gear but what type I have so those
those two things immediately popped into
my head and and outside of that whoa
whoa yeah yeah I mean it's not it's
we've seen these progressions of player
choice and things they finally said
black commemorate it okay pick whichever
one you want to do it's not on this
weekly rotation that was a nice piece of
quality of life it came like you know
three months later but it finally got
there so those were nice to see it just
the fact that it was it was interesting
as they say create an offering for
specific and you're like what does that
mean and then we get the graphics and
we'll get it a lot more but it was like
they're they're definitely making things
very specific and we'll talk about that
more as we get there but all players
have completed the Forsaken campaign and
this is one thing I really want to get
your guy's opinion on will be welcome to
try the menagerie once
as well as access to the Imperial
summons quests so now the way I read
that I want to ask all players who
completed the Forsaken campaign so if
they don't know in the annual pass they
can try this one time do you think I'm
askin because the line next states
owners of Daniel pass will see new
menagerie so it's like their separate
lines and it says all players who have
completed for you and that's was like I
don't know if they were like hey you
bought for a second and you will come
back and try this one time yeah if you
go up to the counter there's a menagerie
in the Annual Pass they don't get it
they'll get a chance they get a taste
yeah basically here
it is which could be doing but I think
that's actually kind of an interesting
way to be like hey do you want to try
the Imperial someone's quest okay you
can do the menagerie one time okay now
do you want to buy the annual pass it's
like almost a demo which is literally
trough I like it yeah that's like good I
like they did that which is better than
saying oh you don't do this you can't
even try gamble yeah cuz normally
they're just they're just velvet-rope
the situation and you can't even look or
touch or go in that area so I agree so
I'm hoping that's true I'm hoping I'm
reading that right for everybody else is
safe so power surge value will be 690
and it is across all characters thank
you for that and then owners a dope-ass
will see new menagerie bosses introduced
throughout the first month concluding
with heroic difficulty and here's where
things get interesting Normal difficulty
match made heroic just like a raid you
have to find your six so what do you
guys think on that one do you think so
we had different difficulties and raids
before and they were not that different
do you guys think they do probably
temper your expectations the same way or
do you think they're actually trying to
set it apart a bit more nice let's keep
it easy
yeah really I think it'll be a hard
difficulty maybe an extra mechanic you
know say maybe but I mean I mean if
they're they're making that distinction
that you need to be premade fire team
then maybe maybe they do have some extra
mechanics they need add-on add a data
requiring communication so what
you think that I'll never see think that
um it's gonna be really deep as far as
what's required I think if it's I think
of it six people and it's pre-made it's
it's gonna have something that has a
handicap to people who are not pre-made
that alone sets it apart I I wonder just
given how we've seen a change in mods if
we're gonna see some additional
modifiers yeah this season some new
modifiers that we have not seen that
will take its toll on communication in a
mechanic you know something in a room
that you just need that they found they
that six random people can't do with
that thing happening or whatever it is I
don't know that's at least where my
brains going with it no I mean I think
that's fair I think it's the point of
like it emphasizes a piece of
communication just like a redwood I mean
if you watch the division right for
example I mean there's no way in hell
you're doing that without communication
same thing here is like their point
whatever they're doing different it's
either stepping up difficulty or rather
just a bit more spun or squishy but
whatever it is if you got a talk it's
probably gonna be needed so it will be
interesting but I'm kind of curious what
that heroic difficulty reward will be if
it's worth it too because if you got to
go find six it's like finding people for
a raid so yeah well and that's the the
power cap on that whatever that is gonna
be because you know that's not going to
remain a six person glide we'll have in
the second week and so on esoterica be
right behind yeah there's there's people
to put my solo work to show it anymore
so it's done and I think that's just
that's what is left open for the you
know your imagination to try to figure
out is what are the what are the things
what are the hurdles along the way there
that I need to you know make sure my
build is right for yes sir
so season of opulent specific calendar
June 4th we've got menagerie and crown
of sorrel launching some people be in
the menagerie some people be doing raids
some people be waiting for the raid race
to get over June 5th
once that actual reset happens crown of
sorrow will go back to normal
so whatever you know power capping is
gone so if you're above that you're good
and then June 11th we've got a new
menagerie boss so kind of the way they
say introduce some of the like nebulae
but it's a new boss so it's a boss not a
new area which is fine with me
I guess depends on how much randomness
we got and we got our first twist yeah
we've got truth so what are you guys
what do you guys want truth to be when
it comes mmm what you think news what
you want what you want
ha this is where I defer a little bit
because my d1 experience albeit lengthy
and many many hours I did not much
knowledge or you know exotic quest
things I know I had truth I thought
you'd never had and I like no no I'm
fairly certain that I did because I
didn't have gallon horn for the longest
damn time so that was my you know yep
yeah my what do they call it my poor
man's gallon yes yes but no I don't know
I don't I don't think really much I hope
I just hope it's good and and I don't
know rocket launchers aren't my stick
but you know they're not a lot of
people's right now I think oh yeah I
mean to till I own touch since I got it
hardly yeah but I don't know if they
find a way to make it viable and give me
a reason to you know yeah yeah I it
needs some help if have it in that power
slot I guess you know good old
horseshoes was used to be good either
she was a check and even ain't enough
these days huh no even look like quick
tracking I mean rocket launchers are so
rarely used there was cluster bombs for
the moment of ribbon and that's even
been overtaken by prospector and things
like that yeah prospector just destroys
her but the biggest thing is the clip
size every rock you in Destiny's zoo has
one in the clip one in the Clinton do
you think truth is actually going to be
the outlier that has more no go ahead
yeah no just to me it had to be I mean
wouldn't wouldn't be truth without it I
think you know but I do agree narrative
says that they've got to
have an additional property they need
something because if you look at it it's
void to tell Fox is void but you know an
insular yeah exactly if what is so
telling is to but better I think it
needs a little bit distinction because
that tracks you know just as well and
then the you know to tail has that extra
property with the what is it the d-o-t
over time and so who's gonna do the bad
omens does get that's exactly the way
I'm looking at it is I have what is it
um what's that a hockey rocket launcher
that I like oh yeah
yeah I got shinobi addy I'm like what
why am I gonna take that off you know I
mean for truth the truth has to do
something actually and you giving me a
quest for right making us specific
investment so one would hope usually
Bungie is very good about you know
making enough changes to something
especially in an exotic quest that you
know maybe you get a little ain't gonna
say outbreak property perfected levels
but it'll get some treatment you know I
mean yeah so I mean we've got two tailed
fox which is a void and solar with
tracking and stunning and burning
nothing does like everything it will
literally like or not yeah like not
stunned but it will suppress the void
and rest in the solar will burn and
that's to and attracts I'm like how in
the hell can truth even compete yeah I
mean you compared just to rocket
launchers that one's already putting out
too so I really don't know you've got
bad it's got to do like it's gotta in my
opinion it's got to do a mana and and
Boop can't and move at the same time an
amplified voice and do splash white
damage and then let me switch the
Rekluse and just wreak havoc if I can
fire one or two truth bullets and then
you get splash and void damages
amplified I'll take out recluse and just
do the rest of the work that works maybe
may I ain't know what I mean and I don't
know and then that itself has to get
buff to do some extra stuff but yeah
biggest thing like truth is always had
the biggest clip size the tracking was
bananas but at this point I mean if you
have tracking a cloth and you don't have
tracking and cluster you already missing
out on some damage anyway because like
bad omens curator lose tracking in
cluster and
like I get enough from that anyway why
especially in a PvE situation that's
gonna be involved in a quest why would I
need something that tracks as hard as it
would need to for PvP it's gonna have
any benefit in comparison so I don't
know where they expect it to be used but
I'll be curious what that thing has
nobody sins was all we were using oh
yeah yeah that's his same as a curtain
call now those are the oh oh yeah
curtain call have one of each of those
yeah so that was June 11th next week we
get another menagerie boss in the iron
banner quest oh so what do you think mr.
iron banner man yes do you think we're
actually going for a legendary and
exotic do you think we're getting
anything worthwhile in here what do you
think we got I'm intrigued by it I like
the fact they if they're doing something
with banner you know saying um I'm very
curious about this because I see if they
still in this experimental phase with
banner right they're still messing
around they had that thing where they
brought in was in rebuke and then they
they had the iron burden and they kind
of take it away they still trying to
find their way what it is seeing so you
know I guess I've had to guess quest I
mean unless they would have said exotic
you know I mean so I was gonna say baby
they tied exotic behind it or something
like that or um maybe some fabled you
know weapons from from banner from d1
that's the only thing I can hope what do
you guys do I know they bring back like
Phil winters lie or something that was
the fusion yeah that was my yeah a pitch
was nice which was nice trying to think
of some classic sumner wins mercy I miss
dad what else some classic banner
weapons back in the day you know so okay
here's the thought you guys are like
being nostalgic over like d1 weapons
after getting truth back you're seeing
some of the other pictures of things
that are coming back are you
are you okay with them still continuing
to use d1 stuff or do you want something
unique what do you think because I mean
we have stuff like I asked Lunas model
but
become an LDR 5001 potentially come in
those will get you in a little bit but
those there are more that seemed to be
looking like d1 and they just keep
putting it back didn't know you guys
thoughts on that one did she take
nervous huh I used to be of them I used
to bug the hell out of me I think the
first year you know rate when it was it
was still sour and you know we had a
sour taste and I'm off from our vault
being exploded and we lost everything to
immediately getting back so that that
was not a good taste however since I
think it works it it just works man like
who cares if I'm shooting good guns and
I'm having fun and and it's just I don't
think about it anymore I guess is is the
number one thing if I don't think it's a
lack of ideas or creativity or anything
on that you know part of it if it is if
it's a quicker to market thing then hell
yeah like keep cranking them out and
take your time to really make some new
exotics that are worth it cuz and I
would have to put this on a sheet
comparatively but I think if we take a
lot of the d1 ones and put them with the
new ones that have been introduced
there's not too many of those new ones
that stand up with the rest of that
funds and that goes for ones that have
been renamed to brought back whisper I
think that yeah I think the new ones
have a lot further to go as far as
exoticness so by all means keep bringing
them back yeah I agree
yeah but you eat uh yeah I mean you kind
of hit it on the head it's like for a
while I'm just kind of like yeah I mean
even seeing some people enjoy to be like
it's just it's another thing to shoot it
opens up the loop pool and we're even
asking for stuff from year one of d2
just like open up a loophole give us
more options and at that point I'm kind
of okay with it too so we'll see
so then June 25th the menagerie heroic
mode starts you know people are gonna be
doing like her wrote a mini heroic
I swear something's gonna happen we'll
see what changes there and then the gun
of so much controversy lumina the quest
so people are wondering is this this is
this that what's it gonna do was it this
thing like what do you guys for one this
is the year of hand cannons like
seriously somebody a Bungie loves hey
whoever makes Quest is like oh I could
how many were mandated in the Activision
I don't know had the usage rates out
[Laughter]
like Lunas and not forgotten which are
kind of in their own mind we've got
thorne we've got not forgotten we've got
this one we've got another question mark
on the other page hand cams are
definitely a popular thing so I'm hoping
this one can stand out the big question
is everybody's wondering is this the
fabled and rumored rose rose and then
there's another picture ever it is like
no this is different and all the other
things so it's another hand cannon I
don't know how much more different it
can be it does look like it has like
yellow thorns underneath kind of the
petals like the grid the design on
that's really cool like the art design
on it's cool but again have you how much
speculation do we want to get into go
let's go have you looked at at like the
enormous size image of that one and
gotten to the details on it look at the
inside it it looks like it's thorn
inside of that as if we reform the thorn
by light the same way that I have uses
or logic ok we use lights of reformed
phone now you got me looking at it
differently and then there are the
barrel rotating around that thing and
yeah I mean not too much else of in
every rosalie though but no I mean like
that day that we got everything and and
then the overview it's like
yeah I'm sorry you saw me going back and
forth with a bunch of people on that and
and then there was the bike video but
lots of speculation on hunt hoes guns
and and equally you know rightfully so
like it's one of the dopest lure stories
in all of destiny mm-hmm
if not ve in my opinion but last word
Thorin all those that I mean they made
an hour-and-a-half movie out of it so
yeah I mean that alone so nobody lie and
then July 9th right before my birthday
and pretty much the day we get back from
Garda cone shout out to everybody by the
way if you are going to Guardian con
kognito and I will be there all this a
couple days after hanging out with my
wife but we will be at the conference
enjoying the fancy schmancy
what is it Rosen Shingle Creek hotels so
they will be tearing it up there so yeah
right Creek it looks real nice so it
should be when we've got the tribute
hall and moments of triumph and then
basically state as we progress through
season more content will come to light
quests will be uncovered leading to
exotic gear the tribute hall and moments
of triumph become available to explore
and complete now I have no idea what to
make of this is this lake let me go look
at a wall of all mile or or all the
triumphs that I've done or is this
actually gonna be like an activity
played MK 11 here sorry I mean the Crypt
yes this could be this could be yeah
yeah yeah maybe yeah I just came to my
mind when I read that like mmm
I mean when isolating the crypts explain
the crypts it's just sort of an homage
to all of MORTAL KOMBAT it's it's the
original island that was in the movie
and and that's the only thing that is
camp but that gets in the world time at
lore which does not matter here
[Laughter]
no you just walk around there's tons of
chests you take a currency that you
learning in game to open up a bunch of
chests and gain skins and stuff like
that and I don't think to that level but
just some of the cool things that you
can find in there that are you know in
homage to years past and in mortal
combat they could be doing here with
destiny and maybe even use that as a way
to sort of foreshadow what is to come
maybe mmm-hmm yeah I mean this is
classic I mean one thing off the top is
it they kept the same symbolism from the
last one you know I mean so which was
one of my favorite I believe that was
the Guardian car shed I went down there
the blue is the blue one with the white
so I like it man you know it's coming
back I think it's gonna be kind of
similar triumph based you know I think
they're gonna have us through a plethora
of different activities to make sure we
kind of experience everything
probably from vanilla on or something
probably gonna make a step foot in a
race of it as well so get prepared you
know you check all the boxes do the
raids at least one round don't need
spire of stars that I have not done
still both gotta join you let me know no
actually I need that too because I need
my sleeper catalyst I believe it drops
from all right I'm gonna need that one
too and I need emo so I can and then
finally we've got July 30th solstice of
Heroes now if you zoom in on that
picture those ornaments actually look
really cool and it says gambit is free
to all even if you own what is it
I guess just destiny to period my one
asking I'm gonna say it right now to
start those ornaments better your stick
they go away after that thing is done
otherwise I'm gonna be just getting
really angry sell better now trouble
armor itself like needs to come forward
I know that was at a time I think before
we started getting the extra slots but
yeah bring that forward and allow us to
upgrade that yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely because I still have the
solstice of heroes ship which was just a
pain in the butt because then he was all
free you had
and I finally got that and I see that
and I never see that ship and I'm just
like but the armor looks so cool if they
have the chroma glowy ornaments on there
that look like they go with each
subclass it has a chance to be cool just
don't take it away bunch you don't take
it away it's all I'm asking yes please
please please yeah they say each week
owners of Forsaken will be invited to
explore the worlds of destiny to in
search of treasure Benedict 44 I'm
hoping he's out of his little cavern
under there is gonna take a while to get
to every time he'll have different
objectives for you complete 750 is the
power cap we knew that was coming and
that pretty much wraps up their basic
thing and then they're like oh yeah
here's this page BAM you go over to the
page of everything for season of
opulence you got the trailer again and
first it's got a little bit of it's got
the animation for kind of what's going
on on the trailer then you get a little
bit of truth you got an ogre coming up
we've got a Minotaur so that's the
menagerie we know we've seen that and
this is the first time we see all these
little rooms they say there's Leviathan
secrets okay
replayability carve your way through an
ever-changing path of enemies that's
what I'm like we'll see how
ever-changing this is I don't know I
don't expect anything crazy high but
then the big one and treasure awaits all
these little runes upgrade the chalice
of opulence to better refine which gear
you earn and the table discusses
specifically about it but we've got all
these different little symbols now my
hunch also on top of that just kind of
how they did a last wish these little
rate these little room yeah they're
gonna be involved in the raid mmm yeah
yeah I wonder if they are like cos call
it you know purple lion or purple or ads
or you know teal ship or something I
wonder if they're gonna do something
like that and use these runes as some
type of kala feature or symbol or if
that would just step on last wish too
much I don't know but it seems like a
very prime thing that I can see them
doing so I would agree agreed then we've
got the new raid of course we don't know
much about that it's just a big opening
so that's that's literally all we know
and let me scroll down to the new
weapons and armor so we've got twenty
images here of different ones
first look what do you guys see anything
stand out to you guys anything look cool
are you getting a theme any question
marks any exotics you see here stuff
like that it's too busy for my taste
he's like I want that proper spacing
that you lie so much I have a proper
could have a new style there's a lot
going on on these armored ISM I hope
there's some ornaments to kind of
flatten it off my trinkets and stuff but
we'll see how it looks when I when I
it's easy to judge it on at night yeah
no I was thinking I mean there was a few
of them that popped over just like okay
well that one might look but like the
scarab beetle in the arm for the hunter
I might miss me with one of the
speculations is that Kepley staying with
the beetle on the ice in the trailer
people who are saying they're seeing
Peregrine grieves that's an easy got the
big Jim's on the knee and the shin you
got truth in here obviously you got a
couple you got a hand game one thing I
was gonna point out outside of the hand
cannon you have a submachine gun sniper
swords sidearm shotgun fusion yes next
and no primaries on here outside of that
hand cannon mhm
no Scouts no horses no autos not listed
anywhere in here I'm like that specific
or you guys showing us what we're not
gonna get or just not putting it all in
there I'm open so hopefully they're just
not putting it all in there I wouldn't
want it all on there anyways same way
they did the trailer no buck everything
seriously but the one question everybody
has the gray plain gun in the middle of
the picture so what what have you guys
heard about this thing because it seems
to spawn a whole lot of speculation for
being just a gray revolver mmm what is
the speculation I'm just curious well
you know now I haven't heard much but
that it is row
that that is rose yep that plain sod
it's bangs alright okay we go let's see
oh I just put the two images over each
other I put thorn and it is a literal
almost replica except for the barrel
location for the bow location
literally everything mmm this is got the
angle in the front the Hammers identical
yeah the grille trigger hammer literally
where everything is it sits to the tee
except for the barrel location
mm-hmm-hmm interesting so you've got
Lumina you've got that thing you've got
thorn and we don't know if that's gonna
be some weird in-between I'm kind of
curious so yeah speculators that could
maybe be the introduction Illumina quest
who knows you know they used to do that
before too they give you a crappy gun
then lets you upgrade it in kind of the
way they did polaris lanes you can get
the legendary and then maybe turn it
into the exotic yeah might be something
so it's just in it's the one that stands
out as being very plain compared to
everything else being very gold and
purple and opulent so yeah exactly it
definitely stands out in that regard
well they're they're saying something
about it but we don't know what shout
out to my Astro site first that was
useless that's coming back then I don't
see here what did that do before I
honestly forget oh the worse it
literally like just extended blink or
something like that and it was very
minimal and very used but it was one of
the coolest looking warlock helmets so
that has to be redone it has to be given
some flavor to it
and in extra properties because I I mean
come on no one I can't just see the
blink property coming back right we're
finished its back so yeah I think they
recognized that that was a cool design
anyone who doesn't give that function
out so yeah gameplay updates power surge
of course the of the first quest it's
nice that it's account-wide everybody
get up to 690 if they do that one if
they've taken a break it's a nice time
to come back iron banner exotic weapons
and armor and then we get down to one of
the things you guys want to earn your
pinnacle weapons so I want to take a
second go over each one and then we'll
break down all of them one by one
so you've got revoke her which is your
crucible one miss shots are returned to
the magazine after a short duration
Windigo gl3 orbs of light increased
blast radius and damage hip-fire
precision shots for sorry hush which is
the gambit one hip-fire precision shots
give a massive draw speed bonus now I'm
gonna jump ahead to the tois just cuz
these are given a bit more detail in
there so I can talk intelligently about
them first one to talk about is gonna be
the revoke er so the unique perk is a
reversal of fortune missing a shot
returns the bullet to the magazine after
a short duration even the greatest of
snipers is not a perfect sharpshooter
and you miss every shot you don't take
so basically they're saying get in there
and take the shot
revoke er was built with the mindset
that you should always go for it and
keep in mind that reversal fortune can
only return a single bullet at a time
along with its unique perk the sniper
has a custom lows oom ambush SL age 25
scope and snapshot for those close
quarters battles first we guys think
about the gun little go over how you
actually get it what do you guys think
of this part do you think it's what do
you think what you think man
it'll be interesting to see how it works
I like that it is on the the lower rpm
sniper because forgiving shots and I'm
you know a rapid-fire sniper would just
be not great so I it's not a pinnacle
weapon in the sense like with when you
put it you know with with recluse and
and Luna just reading the perk itself
you know I think there's something we're
missing they're not telling us there has
to be I I can't see this but equal you
know or conversely I should say that the
the requirement for it equals that you
know the effort I think that you give
you if that is it you know if for a gun
that's gonna forgive bullets you should
be forgiven matches as well I mean I'll
get it either way I'm more excited to
see what we're missing because I do
think that there is something that isn't
being set there
with this gun just something that
returns a bullet that's four times a
charm almost or triple tap or triple tap
you know so yeah right yeah oh yeah I'm
only that's one so yeah I just there's
gotta be something can't be just that it
can you don't seem thrilled by that part
well it's just it's not I mean it's in
the kinetic slot it's gonna be a
legendary it's gonna be masterwork it's
just that when I put them on those same
tears as when I'm looking at recluse and
and Lunas howl what is so great about a
pretty versus magnificent howl or master
of arms that it's not there it's not
even near those two so good I'll jump in
if you finished it I mean I agree yeah
this one is weird you know saying
because it's like the concept is okay
but like like you know now he said it's
one of those things where I just I would
actually that even impressed by this
time I was bored pressed behind you I'll
you know the options of acquiring it
about how that changed and I'm not all
this is do so we want to touch on that
yeah which is like okay you're not
losing progress so basically you you
need to earn thirty five hundred total
glory you don't lose progress when you
know we're losing a match so um that's
different so they're like they basically
wanting everybody to join in on the fun
so in that respect I'm like okay now the
question becomes does this go across the
board is this specific to revoke or like
is this the new wave now a pinnacle like
what do you guys think oh and it's
specific to provoker
just asking about this cuz I was like
going for not for god no I was very
curious about that too because it with
crucible not having many changes at all
I thought that might you know it would a
lot of Guardians would feel inclined to
get in there and then do some things
that they haven't in past seasons
however that's how the
one is being tractive friendly because
on the quest itself it's just cumulative
glory versus you will still lose glory
rank if it's not involved with Robo Kerr
right so yeah you just basically need to
accumulate enough wins they have 3500
glory but your rank is gonna go up and
down just as it always does
so ya lose a match you won't lose
progress towards the gun but lose a
match yeah you'll still be you might be
zero rank you might go up and down
between 60 that's all you're doing yeah
I'm with you guys though as you look at
I mean it is basically a sniper with
Mulligan now in theory my wonder is like
you know some people running would this
thing have less flinch would it be like
would that make it worthwhile if a
sniper with less flinch in is that that
hidden perk is it something that allows
you know like enhanced on you know
unflinching sniper aim is actually
imbued into the gun instead of a piece
of armor
something like that but is it also my
curiosity is like there are certain
people whose night but there's not a lot
of people who feel like sniping feels
good right now is this away for like are
they trying to almost force sniping in
two places but unfortunately the other
pieces I heard somebody say we need them
we need a map or a couple of we need
space to do the sniping right there's a
couple maps whatever Prothean is called
now I forget but whatever there's two
meals bro Theon that's a true snapping
map with lanes like a couple of them
that work pretty well but a lot of them
do not fit I mean people will do no drag
scopes and crazy shots in couple places
but a lot of the maps are too small for
snipers in the first place
and I wonder if this is they're just
like hey you guys should totally try
this it's a low zoom scope I'm like but
it's still a sniper and I'm of the crazy
opinion of like you know when you get
flinched by a sniper when I shoot
somebody with like my pulse rifle and I
hit him with four bullets and they can
still land that snapshot that gives me
off cuz I'm not God and I know but
that's the that's the argument everybody
goes back and forth is like well you
know there shouldn't be flinch I'm like
I just hit you a couple times you should
be able to hit like a pinpoint accurate
shot across the map if I did hit you a
couple times so that's kind of a debate
some people would probably hate me for
but just more people sniping maybe their
goal I don't know but just the fact that
it's Mulligan feels I mean as you said I
granted
Luna's that is one hell of a quest lake
right I mean I finished that thing up
this month
I got 2100 fabled I got reclusive well
balloon is this holy crap and I mean it
feels good you hit the two and then
three and you're just like damn and then
this is just like I get a bullet but it
feels very I mean that's literally it's
like a minute let me hide and cover okay
let me try again like all of this is
giving you incentive to do it more but
not really giving you as somebody said
it's like a fight I made true Vanguard I
think was the one he had a thought about
it and he was just like so if I go on a
tear it's like you know recluse I can go
and just start mowing people down loon
is like I get that perk and start
stacking and multiplying two kills this
one it's like if I hit my shots I don't
get the perk to activate yeah like when
you are good with a sniper you don't get
anything out of this weapon which
sounded really really backwards so I
don't know like this one of course yes
I'm probably gonna go for it but it does
seem like I hope there's something like
you said IRS that we're missing because
if it doesn't this is pretty lackluster
yeah so then let's go up to Vanguard
which actually might be the most
intriguing for a change the Windigo gl3
it's an arc adaptive grenade launcher so
it'll be a heavy drum slot Wendigos gl3
is a unique perk is explosive light
picking up an orb of light increases the
next grenades blast radius and damage
unlike most drum grenade launchers
Windigo comes with blinding grenades as
its magazine option for some added
utility to shut down teleporting
captains or cabal gladiators that get in
your face you can carry up to six
grenades by enhanced by explosive light
so be sure not to let any orbs of light
slip through your fingers when you've
got this equipped so what do you guys
think yeah oh man I mean interesting
interested in this orb of light thing
I'm very curious how it's going to be
implemented right you know you know is
it a situation when you're at full super
does it still have its effectiveness you
know how can you stow it
you know like how is that gonna play I
mean they're saying that you can carry
up to six enhance you know is this like
working in memento mori
fashion yeah how yeah like how big is
the explosion to you know mean like we
got to see you know a lot of this is
still gonna be trial now when we know
for testing in theory it sound like it
could be cool I just got to see how how
was implement what you guys do go ahead
and iris I think yeah in theory it
sounds really cool I'm glad they
explained or used their third bullet
point or no the latter half of their
second bullet point sorry to kind of
describe an instance cuz I didn't I
wasn't too hyped up on it and and that
just them mentioning that kind of in a
way gives me a little bit of hope for
more build diversity yes you know what I
mean like give me a challenge where one
of our guys has to have a when to go on
him like there's too many of those damn
captain's run around yeah somebody's
gotta have a way we gotta shut those
down like you know I think that more
than anything then the gun itself made
me think of of the possibilities of how
it can get used and and like like you
said Lord the the how's it gonna work
with the orbs does that you know it does
it stack is prison for every next bullet
in the drum you know considering it
suppose carry up to six so if I grab six
orbs are all six in the drum now ready
to go you just don't crazy but if
they're blinding what's the point you
know like I guess they're just yes I
mean it's got blinding grenades pretty
much all the time which I guess is just
a function of what you'll be able to use
it by the explosion pieces like if the
blast radius is bigger and the blinding
has a bigger of area of effect that has
a chance to be efficient but I think as
you're sayin Cognito the momentum Mori
is like is it gonna be you know it's
plosive light times six and you fire
times three times do you like as you use
them and then I guess the question is
like while it's equipped that you can
pick them up and it says equips not like
holding it so even if you're like
running around picking up orbs it still
be stacking them on top of you know
you're high and you should be able to
switch over and pull it out that's the
hope and honestly like for grenade
launchers for boss damage honestly
grenade launchers actually are in a
pretty decent spot if you need to dump
them out whether it's like a rally
barricade or Luna faction boots on a
well that still just broke and damaged
which is great you can do so much like
prospector we know breaks ribbon I was
doing warden of nothing the other day
and had prospector out and just
absolutely annihilated the warden yeah
so I mean there are certain points where
grenade launchers are feeling okay you
got to be a little more accurate but I
think this one is you guys are saying it
has potential so yeah it's definitely
better irritation sounding better than
crucible for a change which is Vanguard
yeah Hannah got crapped on for a little
while I mean loaded question has like
the one bullet of a moment and then you
got no scout rifle it it's just a scout
rifle they need love oxygen yeah but
then we've got a gambit we've got a
solar precision combat bow hushes unique
perk is archers gambit hip-fire
precision hits
grant a massive draw speed bonus for a
short duration
now it says hits not kills so it does
just take a hit this weapon is for those
who would proclaim mastery of the combat
bow archers gambit pays out a
significantly better than archers tempo
but it's gonna take a more skilled hand
to get the most out of it make excuse me
make those shots count so thoughts on
this one I'll be honest this was like
just me just me I mean maybe I'm just
terrible maybe it's some functionality
that I can't you know see right now cuz
obviously I don't have my hands on it
what baby as me I was underwhelmed with
these critical weapons you know like
okay it like got a sniper that misses
shots get your little bullet here man
all right Wendigo could be the coolest
of the three no okay you know I'm saying
you know that could be powerful maybe it
gives us that load question you know
power but hush up like I am NOT excited
like unless I see you know one of the
concentrates come out and you know
as me like oh my god it's doing this and
that may be but you know gives you a
massive draw speedball it's like it's
just not setting my heart on fire I'm
not I'm not doing jumping jacks right
now what about you guys you am I going
too hard on it you got first first
reaction is who say yo you know what
they need you know just that the thought
again back to kind of with revoke er I
think there's someone missing here I
think patch notes are gonna lend
themselves to a massive bow bluff it has
to you has to be this link Bible they
have to there's absolutely no reason for
this it's not like this it was like they
got the I don't know that I think you
wanted some little ears I think it could
be a situation where these three
archetypes could be buffed come patch
nose and then in addition and obviously
we see a little bit more effectiveness
but it's just a weird perk about hit
firing LeBeau you know uh what do you
feel about hit firing with a bow or
you're just gonna take the same route
that they're going with the kind of the
same way in the trailer and and this
season they these might only be yeah you
know like because let's be honest when
when we look back at the other seasons
and we go what was shown how much
information were we given and what did
everybody say as a result of it they
didn't want you know what I mean people
were like let's dial it back here let us
be surprised let's find things out right
mm-hmm
I wouldn't be surprised to find that
each of these guns have something else
on them and we'll only and we're being
misled almost in a way okay okay no I I
hope that's wishful thinking like you
know it could it could go that they're
just too basic to in the event that it
does go that route that it's unfortunate
I hope for some passion what's a buff
and put um but maybe a little hopeful
that we're being misled
mm-hmm yeah i'm katya your this is disco
I wanna hear you talk about hush it's
what I'm here for
Hollywood you got fresh man I can't even
follow you to you guys already pretty
much said most of it the only thing I
can think of where it actually could
have some function if you picture a
primeval boss something the big head or
you don't have a card and you get honest
just starting with film cuz bows in and
of themselves I've used like something
like bows in destiny like blew my mind
was like what hold on they're doing to
space know what and then honestly I'll
go through a shadow thrown on you subtle
calamity for like half the damn thing so
like it has moment story like that
single shot can hit hard and if it can
hit hard quickly on a big target like
that's about the only place I can see be
like hey you pop a shield pam pam pam
pam pam pam and if it's able to do it
over and over and over potentially could
be a lot of damage but again you do have
to be accurate you have to earn it but
that's the only place I can actually see
it being useful just walking around be
like oh here's illusionary boom oh
here's this other boom boom well I was
like it's gonna be hard to be turning
and accurate on ads but on single major
boss damage and as you usually have like
60 bullets and a or sixty arrows in a
bow you have a lot of ammo that can
potentially pump out a lot of damage
that's the only place but I've come up
in in my head but I can see it being
useful but generally it was like my
first thing was eurozone's like hipfire
I'm like I'm sorry excuse me that was
what that was my first week at reaction
because I mean hipfire from a bow was no
seriously like I was like you want to be
precise with the bow now you're telling
me to shoot it like last word which I
suck with anyway I'm like ah crap
thank you so what what if you we get an
exotic piece of armor that amplifies
cumulative precision bow shots they're
working to it I want it yeah I see what
you don't it I was like that class is
gonna be real popular well yeah
it's I don't I mean just thinking out
loud again though like the bill that's
very specifics of that type of bill
diversity that you could go
like what they did with the new art
class on Hunter and then with Liars and
now they're you know those two literally
go with each other and we rated for each
other or the Warlock gloves forgetting
their name but amplifies the void
supernova all controversial there we go
converse holds yeah that would be
interesting I mean it would give
viability I hate handheld supernova with
a friggin passion by the way BS that
comes at me out of your hand to make
those bows they're just not like you
said they're they I have an arsenic bite
that wicked can be wicked for very
specific instances the whole wing is
that they they have to be big I can't
take out channel thrall with that no so
we're not static enemies that have late
I mean when I walk down the first part
of the cathedral after you go down the
stairs within descent and it's the
cathedral and I'm clearing out
everything on the side it's just cheap
chic yeah that literally will clear
every sniper in everything from the
doorway and then just walk down an open
room because I'll do it all with the
boat and I'm like that works there but I
mean that's like walking around Rambo
like sniping everything quietly now like
in the middle of a crazy fight like I'm
like that doesn't feel like it's gonna
work yeah especially being gambit is
just too many HP T's exactly yeah I
think we're missing a passion I think I
believe this is sad that we let yo it
gotta be there's gotta be something else
to these right so here's the other side
of the argument do you guys feel they
worried about Lunas that's getting
exchanged do you feel they've made
things that are too strong and now
they're just trying to make things that
are different it's possible it's
possible what the mental
sometime with other meta and and um
obviously you know the Luna they got you
know people if they feel it you know
there is that driven you know they're
very statute and they're very they look
at usage rates and stuff like that and
you know I think maybe they say hey you
know we have to tone it back a little
bit obviously the last update we got hit
with a ton of you know nerfs and stuff
so um you know I think they're just
getting things in line you know with
Pinnacle weapons I always struggle don't
you because it's like you know the the
investment required for these things
right you should have a payoff you
should feel powerful you should have
some level you know of engagement with
this weapon that you've committed to so
to have these kind of perks and you know
expect people who to grind you know and
these ain't knocking anybody socks off
just yet but again I'm gonna reserve
judgment in fairness until we have it or
not so you know people put it through
its paces but right now I would agree
with you I think they're leaning on the
sign of caution with Pinnacle weapons
right now and not going overboard just
yet yeah when you look at the quests to
that the last season for me not as
difficult you know on max mana kill X
and then few X amount of Iraq's fairly
easy to get mm-hmm yeah I mean even like
recluse versus mountaintop is not night
and day like Ginn's
2100 or which mountaintop I'm not even
I've gave it a given up on trying this
season like I can get the kills I can
get like them I think what the first
line of medals were it might be multi
where I'm just like maybe I'll get a
colony but man me and this is where I'm
just probably gonna say I'm terrible the
three kills with grenades without dying
I'm still at zero and I'm almost at 100%
on the top grenade kills and I'm like
dude like that one's just brutal so yeah
that in comparison to just get enough
wins to get your sniper rifle I mean I
think as you said in the beginning of
this iris those can say it wrong I think
it's I think the rewards are now
matching like what it the investment
which is sad because Pinnacle weapons
should be that they should be something
you have to earn and go after and
actually I mean there's got to be a
level of like exotic pinnacle legendary
like some random legendary weapon should
not be equal to my pinnacle it should
not matter so you know it brings up a
good point of I think they need to
there's a line in here I almost tweeted
about it yesterday are we going into the
full 12 okay I didn't want to point out
the one line because it was just it man
did it not I don't want to say bug me
but it just caught me off so off-guard
let's get Tom and it was the the the
line and because we're right here with
fusion rifles you know some exotic
fusion rifles they did minor adjustments
due to inheriting from their legendary
counterparts their minor increases under
5% each this is the line that gets me
this change was done to move legendary
fusion rifles a little closer to the
exotics as the gap between them was
quite large at least in PvE what is the
logic in that linking so back to what
we're saying with pinnacles being too
powerful I there needs to be a clear
vision and definition for them alright
what do these tears look like what is an
exotic or it is a pinnacle and then what
does every legend you know cuz like know
that you should close the gap leave the
gap mmm agree no hundred percent I mean
that's that goes back to when we started
the podcast back and many moons ago
feels like a year and a half now it's a
clean not far from it was the issue of
saying well they're like they want their
line is somewhere in one of their twelve
saying we want exotics to be more exotic
so I'm like yeah like that that the name
exotic should feel I mean you just look
up the dictionary definition and some of
these don't even live up to it and it's
like there should be outstanding in like
these crazy outliers of I mean they want
them to have different purposes but they
should I mean we only get to where one
it's not like I can have an inventory of
exotic I'm gonna be told we get one it
better be good and that kind of goes in
line with what everybody's been saying
about whisper being nerfed and things
like
that it's like fine or you gonna take
skull and make it less good but it's
still better than 90% of the other
exotics so what's gonna make me use the
other exotics unless you have a 20-page
patch notes of why every exotic is now
getting buffed like unless they're doing
something like that people are still
gonna use skull cuz they get back you
know say they get back 2/3 of their
super instead of a whole super and your
capitals like well I still get 2/3 of my
super as opposed to what nothing else so
that's just a major issue that they've
got to figure out for them and what as
you said those deers like some of that
stuff is okay to be a little broken and
leaning a little more into things being
outside of the their comfort box needs
to happen a bit more so yeah yeah I
don't want to debate what you know like
oh well that one's you know it's it's
almost close to that exotic one so you
know I'll run the exotic and the power
slot instead of that with the legendary
legendary is close enough anyways yeah I
didn't have that thought like agreed
yeah when's the last time anybody used
Trinity ghoul when we're talking about
bows like I mean what what is so special
about ok so get it like a 1/2 a string
pulling get the little lightning on the
ground for adds I'm like you're saying
just a bow against little adds no no
just stuff like that so there's a lot of
things that need to reworked final free
summer event is solstice of Heroes so
three pieces pursue the Solstice armor
we'll see if we get to keep it
see if it's useful embrace the light
it's kind of a fun one create Elemental
orbs and I remember when we did this
before resolve our colors on the ground
but it says if you collect 30 orbs you
gain the empowerment buff I'm like I
wonder how long it lasts because 30 is
not a small number to collect and they
said the also I saw if said the
elemental damage of the daily element do
you think it's gonna be like a global
element across like the game like solar
void or arc like changing daily for
Soulstice that's that one that line
right there I had a lot more questions
than I have answers that's a good
question but you know I I'm trying to
understand yeah I mean they
intentionally sometimes write things I
think that aren't you know clear this
leaves them
opportunity while there right yeah you
can still adjust it that would be
interesting you know we're so used to
weekly singes and and then even outside
of that you have you could be in
something with a prism modifier let
alone a EP and are not EP the whisper
mission and reckoning and zero hour now
all run their own singe as well so you
would be looking at a lot of singe
variety we went on a daily rotation as
well it'll be interesting I'm not sure
what to expect from that one especially
with that 30 orbs I mean you guys think
you think something like that would even
work in I mean this is also severe owes
this is always like hey this is your
last month of this year is this like a
little bit of hate collect these orbs
and even like if you collect them in a
raid some of this stuff gets a little
bit easier do you how far-reaching do
you think these orbs will be they have a
tendency to let you with these events
will kind of at least a pattern acting
you know they kind of let you kind of
knock your socks off have fun
you know we had snowballs at one point
you know what's what was it the hunter
force stuff and I think they're gonna
let us get a little crazy you know just
a little bit you know it's the soldiers
it's so it's a fun event
you know reflective event kind of deal
so that's my guy I think it will be a
little a fun time yes I'm rereading
these two it just seems very very in
line with the the other seasonal things
the especially with this be triumphant I
think we'll just get a slew of new
triumphs to go after that are specific
to this event
mm-hm go get your orbs go do all this
stuff and then check off all the boxes
yep I agree I agree so that pretty much
covers the basically season of opulence
page that they put out there at the
bottom of that is the Lumina graphic
which is just gorgeous
well let me get to the table so we
covered a bit of it on the pinnacles so
we're gonna skip around a little bit but
it covers the trailer of what
coming we've got the calendar and then
it says choose wisely so we're gonna
come back to the menagerie and how this
little chalice of opulence actually
works so I'm gonna read some of this and
one kind of deep dive into it just so we
can actually have their piece of context
Calais would see you grow fat from
strength during season of opulence
you'll be granting players the chalice
of opulence which serves as player's
gateway to treasure players who emerged
victorious in the menagerie will use the
chalice to serve up an offering of runes
in exchange for a weapon or gear they
choose from a selection of items
available I don't remember that line of
selection of items available maybe it
rotates the treasure you will be
treasure you find will be limited at
first but over time you'll be able to
upgrade the chalice to acquire more
plentiful and powerful rewards each
player will claim their chalice at the
start of the season through the
introductory quest which is what
everybody has to do to even do the raid
so how does it work earn runes the slot
on your chalice through the following
complete weekly bounties opening up
weekly chests on the new nessus barge
which i think is that gold chip that's
floating out there and then demons we
were talking about and using a
consumable that will reward you with a
rune after a strike crucible or gambit
completion the same consumable also give
other players in your fireteam a chance
to earn an additional rune so that's
actually cool it actually works for
everybody
slot thorns in your channels before
entering the menagerie play the
menagerie to earn your rewards
completing the menagerie will award you
gear you choose with your rune
selections each rune affects what you
receive and some of its properties
depending on how you slot them so I also
say it's upgradable you'll have a host
of new triumphs and bounties to complete
the reward new currency called Imperials
using these Imperials you can upgrade
your shelves to acquire a variety of
perks with a wide range of effects and
from giving you more powerful rewards
reward perks per week to allowing you to
choose the specific gun and master works
that but you get from men at the
menagerie you you can earn Imperials in
several ways completing weekly bound use
certain triumphs using special
consumables chalice upgrades you choose
which upgrades you unlock first unlock
additional rune slots to allow more
control in vitam special
unlock it so you earned more runes and
moon variety upgrade it to for
additional power so all that being said
there example is as follows which sorry
long waited but wanted to say at all so
for example if you wanted to earn a
random role of a beloved sniper which I
guess they're talking about the LDR
that's sitting below with handling as
the master work trait you would use a
rune of jubilation any red and any
purple room this room configuration is
your freebie the only one they're gonna
tell us we're excited for the community
to come together and uncover the
combinations of each menagerie reward
and I'm sure some crazy spreadsheet will
get existed so now that all that's out
there
NARAS now that you've kind of gotten
into this detail this is this speaks
you're gonna have the best infographic
in the world for this so follow this man
on Twitter if you haven't done it yet Mr
underscore in IR is he is eventually
gonna have the graphic of all graphics
for how you do this but this is gonna be
fun I thought when I saw this the screen
for the first time I lost and then after
reading it even more I just it was if it
does what it's supposed to do and what
it's talking about like it's a dream you
know in a way I think how all of these
things operate in tandem and then
equally figuring out what those
combinations are gonna be to get those
roles I mean we're talking hundreds of
Conniff not more of combinations to get
very specific roles you will probably
see more than one infographic on this
hahaha like here's how you roll the
sniper here's how it's gonna be wild but
equally like I'm super super stoked to
see them embracing this level of wow
what's the word I want Chile's say yeah
but also crafting like yes with a
challenge involved as well it's not just
a handout it's not just go
get X amount of things and make sure you
got them and then push the button and
voila oh you because is that what you're
implying sir no prophesies for you right
right it I'm just stoic I'm super
excited I'm very curious to see what
these things on the bottom are going to
offer its incompatibility things bonus
things you know it's that what gets us
our traits in in in a weapon line or
certain things on armor man this is uh
this is big this is what I was talking
about when you take the oven and you mix
it with the synthesizer check a little
bit yeah it's easy baking and it you
know this we're looking at the master
work version of it too so it ain't gonna
be no that's gonna get handed out no
that's gonna be heroic for sure and
probably a question multiple completions
each boss around something like that so
yeah an equally you know do then is that
all the things that are opening up on
the bottom as it goes along you know
what what are we limited to given that
we see everything here on the master
word version what does it look like when
it's rare offenders over here now you're
baking with big words
wow he's out of control dying right now
that's great Larry but honestly for me
like you say the word crafting and I'm
just like yes like crafting is a huge
step in an awesome direction for this
game because something we've never had a
specific choice to go after I want to
craft this that put these Jim's it like
almost like it reminds me of Diablo and
socketing gems and figuring out those
types of things that leads me down that
path and like almost of her Audra cube
of like combine these three or four
things and bam you get this thing but
it's like combining these three or four
things
now go do this activity okay now you can
get this likes but like when they say
you can pick a like the handling master
work like you can go that specific that
is bananas like okay so hand cannons I'm
going to range mess worked the whole
time when as soon as you figure that out
somebody's going to want to know
like you want auto rifles like if these
are all in here as an option man that's
gonna be you are gonna have some work
sir it's good they're gonna have to have
some risk reward to it you know like if
if it's if you are going to define and
this is a speculation if you are going
to define a very specific role that you
want in that instance is it then
required that you do the heroic version
of the menagerie
you know you then saving that thing like
hey I have everything here for my
perfect role of this I'm not setting
foot in there until I know I got five
competent Guardians with like hey guys I
got you know you go hit your homies like
mm-hmm
I'm ready to do this one like I've been
saving this this is my role let's go
like we cannot lose because that will
holy can you a matte like that would
bring together here you want like
because right now in reckoning you keep
getting your little runes back and
honestly you're just like oh we didn't
make it well let me just leave and go
find another group because we said yeah
you're right you're right so I mean in
the normal matchmaking I'm sure it's
gonna be like okay these are lower tier
things we're not gonna use all your gems
whatever now once you get up in though
the runes and you're like as you said
you find that six-person match made
curated okay you guys got your act
together nobody's got to leave we're
okay we're doing this like if there's
absolutely weight to it actually losing
that'll put even more to it so some
people may not like it but that actually
gives the activity weight which means
that accelerators though you could
probably eat your random role still but
I'm thinking in that one instance where
it's you know what's coming out of that
thing when you get those gems together
and people are gonna be hurt if if y'all
don't pull it off like there's a French
it goes down the same crafting destiny I
think is a stretch and it's like and it
maybe it's like I know we're we're
hoping it's something like this but I
mean if they say you can literally pick
a a specific sniper rifle and they said
one line is like from what's available
so maybe there's certain weeks you
got options of what's available for boss
encounters or the boss related like
likeness of Oryx the same way that
inventory shuffles for likeness of works
and the swords I'm sorry yeah you know
knows was gonna say CI depending on what
week we're on what burn is in there
whatever is going on like all that stuff
is gonna factor into what you can get so
maybe we'll see so but that actually I
mean that's probably one of the most
exciting things I think all of us are
over this entire season is that piece
right there
what you can do with that actual chalice
versus how even with all all of destiny
to even that just gets me so excited
this was probably the best news and
unsurprised it was very very surprised
very surprised because I'm like this is
something community went for a long time
and to have that customization to have
that configuration and when I read like
hey if you want because that's the other
thing when they introduced the master
work system to me that was the only
flawed part which was when you got the
ran well there was no way to control
that Kirk that your master would hate if
they just you did is there's RNG all the
way so to have a system like that to to
figure out a combination to figure out
what that master is gonna be like you
said he you know you know you're going
on range if you can find what that is on
hand can it
yeah there's certain ones that are just
gonna be like money so to find that is
just real cool and and just like you
grind up this random row grinding like
this adds a whole different layer you
know and that's I think black rmally
attempted it on a small level we're just
trying to grind for you know different
guns and stuff like that and I actually
did like the gameplay loop of it but
this is even further and this is kind of
what you know destiny fans have been
clamoring for since like deep one and
wasted a whole bunch of materials just
reroll stuff and back in them days you
know there's a it's exciting it's
exciting I can see hours upon hours this
stuff it's as we think it is and it's
done right yeah it's just like like now
I said it I I'm super excited this is
probably one of the Loki the best parts
of the info-dump
that we've seen from a table in my
opinion I think you guys pretty much
said it all I don't have much to add on
top of that because
I just yeah I kind of want to get in
there and that's just gonna be every
doesn't at first ever it can be like all
right well slot these in okay what'd you
get
Naru you select these in is it the same
thing okay like what makes it different
so so much trial and error like the raid
secrets reddit thread is gonna be
bananas cuz we're gonna post up like
crazy spreadsheets and probably to your
Chevys or sweat circles or glads for the
crazy spreadsheets but if you want it
looking pretty not in a smashed-up
spreadsheet go look tourmaline right
here that's the man right D he's gonna
make it look good easy to read and be
like I don't want this with this cool
right here done awesome he's gonna have
you hooked up so follow him if you
haven't he will you're gonna have some
work though sir that's already last
night I was trying to think I'm like how
do I want to do it you know how do I
want to set it up infographic that is
his weapon at least wha did I just
scroll yeah like weapon do I start with
weapons so I start with runes to it you
know I'm look it's gonna look good I
just I just wait to see itself I know
but that's fine you do them and nobody
might see me for all of July crafting
why is he not a guardian he is working
he's working right now he's in overtime
mode okay let me zoom as Oh eggs so yeah
honestly it's pretty exciting we'll see
how specific we can get but I'm very
very curious just like you guys are for
sure because you guys said basically
everything I was thinking is the
crafting the specifics like can I go
after this what is it gonna take like is
it are you gonna risk losing things like
so many questions we have and I think
that's been kind of a nice piece about
what they've given us they've given us a
pretty good amount of info but we still
have questions about just about
everything which is how it should be
it's like a movie trailer done right
like hey agree this is gonna be Star
Wars you know the force awakens okay
what the hell is the movie about I don't
have a damn clue until we see it cool
that's how it should be done like same
thing here so I don't know quite what's
happening but we will see so now we get
down into a couple buffs for weapons
fusion rifles outside of your line that
kind of took some
Sonic's gamer new Greg with the twitch
prime sub had to shut you out real quick
thank you very much just because that
wasn't mopped up fusion rifles non
exotic fusion rifles damage increase it
against PvE combatants for fusion rifles
that alone is good that's nice I fired
at one the other day I was like come on
mm high impacts increased by 30%
decision by 44 adaptive by 44 and rapid
fire by 47% mm-hmm that's a lot actually
we're almost talking about 50% damage
bonus there mmm-hmm while some of the
exotic fusion rifles Telesto yotan
merciless did receive minor adjustments
due to inheriting their legendary
counterparts their minor under 5% each
but yeah I mean fusion rifles getting a
buff you guys like gonna be pulling
anything specific out like is remaining
greedy until you know getting a good
viewer you guys still just chill I'm not
it's this is me right here cuz I'm
mister loaded question so this is all
when I saw the ad I was like oh this guy
I know the question man is really you
know warlock mean you know I throw on my
luna faction it you can you can get busy
with it you know I'm saying you time it
right and use the autoloading holster
and stuff just to give your teen that
blast so yeah I'm excited about this you
know I'm saying I'm curious to see they
say it exotic food and rifles only what
is it 5% increase or nose I guess the
question I got though someone's get
confused cuz I feel like fusion and
linear fusions in its way apply to my my
infamous my baby oh as my baby's
sleeping that part of this love sleeping
linear yeah no I had to feel I was like
it's probably gonna be flavor but oh
yeah I mean listen overall this is this
is good you know because fusions I don't
really think of being used in PvE that
often you know that's just I don't know
what you straight I don't see them a lot
so yeah this would be called a they need
a slough they need a some look what do
you think nervous I'm just I'd I don't
use one really that often loaded
question it's great I need it with
something as powerful in the kinetic
slot so to use that Auto loading like
all I do is pull it out for
that one should I had you know I had my
with it and then and then back to
whatever
however I would like to bring back out
main ingredient um I would also like to
begin to use you know Prometheus and
cold heart again like I have all of
these things master work and no reason
to use them oh but also those rifles oh
no I'm but bill just agent or like
when's the last time they gots
Prometheus got a nasty though yeah bro
you gotta dust it off maybe I do yeah
that's not dog Prometheus is the last
couple of updates it's very strong I was
very fond of it amplifies damages along
yes I want attorney at a big soul of all
it's bigger bigger bigger yeah but yeah
overall I mean like I think it would
give me a reason to use my side of PvP
maybe knock sounds a little specific of
a role but I don't know I can't it would
give me I any buff always gives me a
good reason to dive back into the vault
and see what rolls I hung onto for
whatever reason you know and and a
reevaluate basically I think that's
always fun with any sandbox change and
hopefully these buffs you know give me a
reason to grab one and bring it back
home so next we've got Sturm and Drang
haven't heard about those ages these
poor bastards seriously yeah storm and
stress max overcharge rounds increased
to 99 so apparently you just like stack
it till you're blue in the face yeah
Sturm overcharge buff text now displays
the number of overcharged rounds
overcharged damage increased by 100% in
DV so the reasoning for this was Sturm
and Drang were weapons that lost a bit
of their place in PvE once forsaken hit
I mean yeah cuz they said not being able
to carry around a special weapon hurts
your output so Sturm fell to the wayside
with these changes along with a new
version of drain coming out in season of
opulence so I guess something with
either random roles or better perks we
hope that it is some time to shine again
I feel like me I just want to say like
this is one of those points where
bungees like hey somebody had a really
cool idea of weapons to work together
let it
they try to figure but you don't like
the binky in your back yeah so I mean
honestly for me it's one of those I'm
like how could it it's not gonna like
like it's not gonna compare to a shotgun
or a fusion rifle or a sniper rifle in
that slot so hey hey that's my opinion
I've never used those guns like hardly
ever I mean I know people had some
montage moments of like stacking them
and you can probably sitting in the
power I'm gonna have to get the single
shot but like mmm that's literally like
can you craft the perfect scenario to
use this once that's my opinion it was
like this is always just like okay yeah
we get a new drink sure might be a cool
sidearm but is it really really worth it
but how our sidearms doing yeah where's
that patch note buff come on like sound
like there traits aren't viable mmm God
still got some sick rolls it's waiting
yeah I've got quite a way that I haven't
broken down cuz I'm a I'm a hoarder
to the worst yeah my mom is always full
and I'm just like maybe and somebody's
like I was something I was like what
about these the office some okay rules
here and they're like I just break down
every one of those I see I'm like but
maybe now swords now this is probably
when I kind of expected because we had
two swords in that graphic of although
all the weapons and stuff that we were
getting and so yeah the fact that we're
actually getting a pretty decent talk
about swords is good so anybody want to
read this one since I've been saying all
of this stuff yeah go go capacity
increase to a max of 70 starting ammo
increase by 10 black talent is gonna get
ground and aerial projectile ammo cost
increase from 3 to 4 that France or is
they up ground
uppercut ammo cost increase from 3 to 4
aggressive frame now lunge a target with
an aerial light attack flat attack can
sit it into a single damage event slam
attack
consolidate excuse me into a single
damaged man slam attack ammo cost
increased from three to four then we got
the lightweight lightweight frame damage
tuning so ground light attack increased
by 17% aerial light attack decreased by
21% ground - attack increased by 87%
interesting aerial - attack increased by
78% no ammo aerial light attack
decreased by 49% okay and all other no
ammo attacks they like stop cheesy
decrease about 50% ground - attack mo
increase cost increase from 2 to 3 so is
it getting some adjustments we increase
ammo capacity but also increase the cost
of heavy attacks proportionally to
encourage mixing in light attacks to get
the most out of them instead of just
repeatedly using attacks also much like
how dragon will show up in the new forum
for the season of opulence the
lightweight and aggressive swords are
getting the same treatment so which at
Bank man soars how ya feeling about
these I don't use one there's like a bow
anywhere after you use a sword limit and
all I do is probably heavyweight
uppercut but I was like in the moment
unlike a guy it's like okay shirt hits
pretty hard if there's like a Solar
shield don't get a solar sword probably
gonna do some damage to them but it is
always the risk and it's an issue why
massive risk yeah cuz your proximity any
to any enemy is always a risk much less
anything powerful because there was
freaking stop you and that's a major
issue have heard you know people like
Dustin talking about just go absolutely
off on like why does every every damn
boss have the ID sleigh mechanic
everything and and when you're on the
bridge the same thing oh let me be on
this confined space in the middle of
chaos of what you get a nerf our supers
and now you're gonna have a slam
mechanic or a boot mechanic like other
not other ways to manage us there's fire
there's fire yeah set you on fire that's
the other one from the Knights so if
they don't poop you they you're sitting
on an effort house you're roasting yeah
you're roasting your crispy or regular
and extra-crispy I guess but yeah I was
like I mean swords having the maximum up
to 70 but then they they increase the
you know cost of the heavy attack and
you're like it's kind of like a kind of
a hey uh like a little bit of a one two
steps forward one step back I guess they
want you to lose light attacks a little
more yep
I mean and the damage sounds good for
the lightweight frame I mean the other
ones seem like it's mostly just kind of
slightly changing some stuff up some of
the like you know the lunge attacks if
you actually lunge to the target in in
the air that's a good thing as opposed
to like here's the guy standing here I
jump up in there and I swing at nothing
as opposed to actually getting to them
so little tweaks are good but I still
don't know if the way I mean if we still
have minotaurs and ogres and everything
in the slam I don't know where I'm gonna
really bring this thing out and be like
a point I'm gonna go smack the boss like
you're gonna die dude don't do it facts
just like we talked about it before just
a way mechanics are structured I mean it
almost forces you to fight at distance
so that you can avoid those type of
mechanics you know I'm saying that's why
those long range weapons tend to
dominate in those heavy slots and stuff
so swords are just still gonna struggle
you know I'm saying until until they
find you know better mechanics with
bosses like you said like until you have
like more situations of fighting Kali it
actually run up and stuff and you know
the other than that you know like you
said that big old stock comes down you
gets it down the block
there's your sort action so it's a ways
to slide you know so mm-hmm or if they
could just find better ways to maybe
incorporate them with different things
on the skill tree yeah I don't know
something give me a read you know what I
mean like I wouldn't you would gladly
take you know my warlock sword there
that that is specific and if it could
give me five to 10% a health increase
when I use Phoenix dive I would bring
that in like cuz that got nerve to high
hell yes big time you know what I mean
though something that is very it's a
it's a use case but it makes me want it
makes me think about using a sort I
don't even think about swords right now
that might be me and just how I play but
yeah they did something else needs to
happen because it's like you said it's
purely the the
that that situation there's just the two
game quote too many stops you can't just
just make sense hey what about you you
mean it
I don't mean it
I don't have anything no no no I mean
the same thing you guys were saying I
mean I know what they're trying to go
forward giving you a capacity making
sure you don't use heavy all the time
but it's the mechanics of the encounters
that really take away and less like I
can't go touch bosses I'm gonna be the
guy who just goes and smacks around
enemies with a sword you would have to
have a specific role but generally it it
doesn't benefit you to have that role
versus just being more of a well-rounded
player so there's no point where it's
specific to be like hey I gotta take a
sword and go slash this guy yeah I'm
probably not akin to Windigo maybe we
hopefully could be seeing some more
mechanics and instances that allow for
those very specific uses hmm cross
fingers fingers toes hands arms honestly
cuz I would love nothing more than to do
that than our proverbial you know who's
got whisper who's got yup
you know who's runnin prácticas runnin
you know I would I would like to very
much you know right in there absolutely
absolutely so that's all we have for
patch notes at least at this point as to
whatever else is gonna come next week
wait for Tuesday while you're
downloading cuz that's when we'll know
yeah we've got Raiders of the Lost vault
so they've got the raid belt graphic
definitely gold and purple is just all
over this thing
from the graphic man what do you think
how'd they do I any belt they do is
gonna be it's gonna be great
oh yeah anything
god he has to be you know just you need
maybe the job noxious yeah mm-hmm so we
know that's gonna be the world's first
race is for the belts first team of six
uh they actually have official world's
first rules as well main pieces it's
just the the final six members are who
will be the final six is not anybody
involved it's not if you switch them out
so apparently they're saying they're
okay with you switching them but the
final six are the ones who actually will
be crowned per say the world's first so
if you help on the first encounter
you're like alright this other guy's
gonna go level and you're like you know
you're pinch-hitting for a little while
and you get yeah you're not gonna be
getting a belt so just remember what
part you're in just know that maybe
without being history but this is the
thing that seems a spark everybody's
question are you an avid reader and you
don't think you can finish first well
there are so some other enticing awards
available those brave enough to tackle
the rate encounter soon after lunch if
you are able to defeat the final
encounter in the first 24 hours you'll
receive the heavy is the crown emblem
now this emblem is working a lot of
questions as to what we're gonna fight I
don't know if you guys have seen that in
blood the very specific little oh I woke
up to like 18 mentions from really I
don't know like just cuz i retweeted
something from somebody I try to debate
but the question is everybody thinks
that is actually gonna be related to the
hive because that symbol is very very
similar to something related to crota
that I saw somebody put a picture up and
looks that graphic looks not quite but
damn near identical to crota's slake
kind of symbol situation and it's I mean
it's black and green it's it's the high
very high V very high graphic II so what
does that make you think about the rate
as we think crown of sorrow and then
heavy is the crown emblem what the hell
crown do you guys think they're talking
about mmm I think a lot of people are
missing the the other design aspects of
this with the the radials on it as well
they're like that's not hive at all
mmm that's that's very callous oriented
those leviathanic about whatever those
triangles and and you know what I mean
like that and that pattern that's very
very very so think of things but five on
the Leviathan do you think there are
like some come or do you even think hive
is involved do you think it's just like
as you said like a mystery or like a
switch like they're trying to trick us I
think that the press kid had that one
shot of the Minotaur that was looking
kind of rusty and and bad it's just it's
nothing we've seen yeah you know very
much like when we went to Mars we saw
the high explody hive or yeah frozen was
frosty hive there we go
yeah I don't know it'll be interesting I
think a lot of the aid
if there's one theme years we're not
being told everything yeah
so again I think we could be
intentionally being misled it could be
those colors to make us think that but
you look a little deeper into it and it
might be something else I'm not enough
of a lower guy to I mean I know a lot of
it but nothing to speculate with
confidence what this could be
mmm I just know I gotta have it just
like tentacle greenie
yeah I know that's definitely something
I want so I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do it or I'm just gonna die of
lack of sleep but I do want to give that
thing a try so I'm thinking there maybe
there's a high boss or maybe it's a
final encounter and she's doing I don't
know but people have wondering Claire
keep saying like XIV some weird name
okay I forget what it is they keep
saying is either ass yeah is that one of
the sisters right yeah that's that's or
it's a third sibling
yeah so there one that sin volved and
I'm late
so everybody's her and sad that are left
after we took out so maybe it's her as a
tease and then sounds like alright you
killed both of them
I'm bringing the triangle ships and here
we go triangle ships people think or the
veil like is she
like so no no idea honestly but it does
it spoke high when I first saw them like
this doesn't run like the ordinate
doesn't look like that at all so there's
something something different going on
in there is something's gonna happen and
then if you can't do it in the first 24
hours which I still want to try if you
do it in the first a week you can get
that rain jacket now they did change up
the actual look it's not quite the big
puffy bomber jacket actually it looks
more more like just a legit jacket mmm
the inside on the back though oh man
that's mean look I am NOT a close person
at all I could care less I but the
inside of the jacket is just cool
because I know I'd be wearing it but
just actually it looks like a pretty
good jacket - it was like I don't know
this is actually one that I made and may
actually try and go for oh man I mean I
gotta give it up like even the bomber
jackets before me this one is definitely
I gotta give it up on the entire man
everything that was in fashion team they
were doing a thing man they out here ice
that is nice I like that a lot so yeah
my join you ate and how am I gonna see
if I can get down with these threads
nice yeah I mean that one yeah that one
I don't know something about the doesn't
it has a different feel like a jacket I
live in Texas it's not as cold down here
especially not Minnesota that's one like
me if I actually do want like I don't
have a great jacket I'm like is that
okay good good lightweight the colors
all different so it's not a bomb yeah I
thought I had to poke a little fun at
that you know that the seasons of which
these are coming out and so this people
will literally get in winter so I'm like
cuz like I'll get my my my scourge of
one when it's hot as [ __ ] out here but
no I'm I'm on board like yeah and and
I'd shared the same sentiment like
whoever is is in the work in the fashion
on this as
I don't know if Zoey did these or who
but while we while you out yeah it's a
spicy jacket then of course there will
be more stuff at the store starting on
June 4 so stay tuned for the callous
shirt and I got a lady's thanks so
coming next week for season of opulence
we will see update 2 point 5.0 issues
they are getting fixed our quick brief
ones they've got fix an issue where
heroic aversion of 0 or would only be
available as first character the
luxurious toast emote now allow players
to sit for as long as they desire I just
want to sit players can no longer win
crucible matches by getting kills after
the timer has expired I don't even know
if I've ever come across that
specifically this one for me is probably
one but you've never snuck in one more
come on no no I've gotten I've gotten
the kill afterwards I don't think it's
ever gone a victory I don't think it
ever counts so oh god those I had a few
of those no really no oh it is bizarre
cuz it'll say you lose or Shaq says you
lose but those greens as you want and
I'm huh you're just sittin you're just
kind of a little conflicted at the end
yeah yeah they have a weird thing where
the timer's in same thing when you're
running like a nightfall strike like as
soon as I kill the boss that time around
a freaking end like there's times when
I've been like close to a point
threshold then it starts ticking down
yeah and they like that yeah so like
some of those take longer but this one
fixed an issue where the action for
applying shaders ornaments Holograms
we're using consumables was getting
cancelled and not applying on the first
attempt like I don't know how many times
on PC I'm like hold the button don't
work Apple didn't work gamers rejoice
that's just a quality of life one that's
huge for me there are still actions that
will cancel the apply but function but
the fact that hopefully works correctly
thank God
players with multiple radiant matrix
materials in their inventory whatever
but then we come down to the pursuits
they're actually mixing up your pursuits
into full bounties
and everything on your director now so
very good change very good cottage so
the pursuits menu will be moved from
your inventory to director with this an
update you'll be able to switch between
pursuits and director overview in one
move the subject with the objectives
displayed in the new tab it should be
easier than ever to get your plan for a
gameplay section knock out some
boundaries they also increase the size
from fifty to sixty three as well see
you guys multiple pages more space yeah
honestly I always have too many damn
boundaries anyway so we've added some
filters so you can do quest only your
bounties only so I mean a little bit of
quality life here but honestly that's
that's another one I'm looking forward
to it's just gonna be a nice aesthetic
to it all this better not come gunning
for my weekly reset graphic to do every
week Bungie you don't take it away
whole video over that one sale yeah
you're you're good but yeah
timing for Tuesday so 7:00 a.m. destiny
maintenance will begin 8:00 a.m. this is
all Pacific time by the way destiny to
in communion features will be taken
offline patch 2.5 bono will be rolling
out across all platforms and then at
noon normal reset is when everything is
supposed to come back on so I've got a
couple hours to download it they talk
about players on console if you need to
power cycle their console whatever it is
work on getting that thing to start
downloading takes a little while but
you've got two hours so if you're going
for that race man as soon as that thing
takes off start cycling do what you can
to do to get that thing to download so
they're trying to give you as much time
as possible and they will be calling the
world's first via Twitter every player
will have to do the imperial summons to
be able to even try it and then from
there you'll see
but yeah 707 20 will be your max and
then they have an amazing wallpaper by
the way it's what's sitting behind us
actually as we record this thing is your
chalice and there's a 4k version the
wallpaper out there that is honestly
looks really really cool with basically
like the is Luna in just in case you
guys were wondering be like hey Bungie
you've thrown all the season of opulent
stuff at us we've had so much to look at
we're trying to
into these pinnacles and what's every
gonna going on all these mysteries oh by
the way they tweeted something out
saying tweet tune in for the reveal of
the next chapter of destiny to Thursday
June 6th two days later after that
season goes live they are not joking
around they're saying raid jackets
awarded Lake whoever gets it
now we're going like okay so this is the
big question it was a nice little spicy
finish here thoughts whatever wants to
that's all I can say you know I have a
lot yeah I have not a whole I just have
imagination wild over eating it probably
yeah and you know is the background of
the image of any significance I don't
know that that became a thing that we
were kind of tossing around and I
haven't seen anybody bring this up and I
had to reply to hot gun yesterday
because she was kind of initiated this
whole search of what this background
image is okay
trying to figure out if it's location
anything really and ultimately a lot of
heads just kind of decided to a it's
just very reminiscent one director and
then I think they actually did find the
location mom they don't had to relate to
d1 again though somehow I think don't
quote me on that however what a lot of
people aren't bring up and and this
really am so I'm glad I get to mention
again did we all forget about Luke
Smith's letter in one of the twelve
mm-hmm months ago mm-hmm with a very
very very very specific set of words at
the end of it repeat them did you would
keep those yeah yeah
and in he so you know all of this draws
back to the fact that I think well not
that I think the possibilities are there
when I look ahead and think about
destiny and where it could go I see a
bright future with roots in a memorable
past not everything has been lost in the
dark corners of time soon you know that
was a very you know just that's how you
sign off a damn letter you just want to
break somebody with OCD yeah right so I
don't know I don't want to get too
insanely speculative because next week
we're gonna know something so you know
this this d1 port thing oh I don't it
oh I wish I hope that would be that
would be so rad and I don't think it's
gonna happen so that means that I don't
know what it means
honestly I have no idea
I think the mystery it gets me more
excited than anything just knowing that
it's there knowing that he had said
those things and then just the community
having fun you know trying to figure out
and and like I said probably over
reading it you know over analyzing but
in the event like that's some hella
cryptic messaging if if it ends up being
something like that it wouldn't be the
first time that you know a background
images is of significance in something
else in trust yeah interesting what do
you think just sitting there smiling you
know so I remember the conversation we
had last week we were both wrong and I
was like yeah I was like I got Saved by
the Bell by the Jeff Keely talk yes
so to give Maris context on what he
missed was you know we were talking
about basically the future of destiny
post Activision deal okay um I've got
some good friends you know corporate
lawyers and has a brother that works at
Bungie yeah it doesn't help you to help
with Bungie sorry this but um you know
the the speculation is that you know
once season of opulence ends they are
free from the contractual obligation to
Activision and thus they are essentially
on their own right which leads us to
believe okay so then what happens we do
know with um the PC port you know I
believe was if I carry us yeah visions
and those guys and you know the
battlenet that Siri Connie that very
kind of in right so they the question
becomes one the format of how destiny
structure do they retain the annual pass
structure again you know which is one
rumor that we've heard do they go back
to the comet style you know thing and
the other part of it is in in that whole
contractual agreement PlayStation had
exclusivity right that was part of the
deal they had those exotics they had
those stuff that to my knowledge to
corporate lawyers should is ending yeah
so that whatever can right so what
happens now what does Bungie do so I had
some theories I was throwing them out
you know against the wall and you know
one thing is III is the biggest showcase
event that's the big you know as a
developer as a publisher you want to
showcase if you want to make an
announcement you make an announcement
there now I had a theory in conjunction
with Microsoft not saying they would go
exclusive but maybe some sort of
marketing rights on the console side who
knows where they'll go on the PC side
you know if you have epic store buying a
lot of stuff out here and then you have
steam you know still huge base and a lot
of people below the thing that I extract
me is again I have made my prediction
before and then you know we heard the
news saying you know they were gonna do
a reveal on their own June 5th or 6th so
I'm like okay they control the narrative
it might not be that big announcement
right but then when I seen Geoff
Keighley tweet and he's like hey I'm
gonna sit down with the team at Bungie
during e3 Coliseum for
panel title the future of bungee and
destiny to on Tuesday June 11th they're
known excited for what they have to
reveal next week next week so I'm like
why is Geoff Keighley involved and why
is bungee at e3 USA like that to me that
signifies big announcement you really
want to showcase so again I'll go hold
on to my theory you know which is uh
maybe Marcus or suits in with someone
just a marketing they're not exclusive
you know and because we know for exact
they're going to be at president III you
know Sony is not present at e3 um well
see let's see if my theory cuz you'll
get its longshot it's connecting dots
I'm not guaranteeing anything of just
speculating based on Bungie situation as
a free agent you know there may be
wanting to expand in that role and then
we do know the last part of my little
theory my little thing is that you know
we do know when the reports came out
that Bungie was the one that really
wanted to push cross play cross
progression all those kind of things and
being free of that Activision / Sony
deal maybe we get back into that utopian
thing where could you imagine you know
as PC gamers being to jump into that
pool you know and then more speculative
stuff now I'm really gonna got my
tinfoil hat or now you know we have the
whole you know Microsoft and Sony cloud
partnership deal that just recently
happened so eventually maybe not right
right now
maybe d3 right we get to that point of
true cross blades from cross progression
cuz we do know that something Bungie one
so I'm excited I just want to see oh
yeah the whole industry's going now
Sony's the only ones yesterday yeah that
blew my mind I'm be like oh it's gonna
happen old cross play and I was like
that is I think it was chef Paul Tassie
he's like he said like the dam is broken
yeah that's the start of it bro I think
we're here and again there's no excuse
on the Sony side because if they're
gonna be using the azure structure
background in the future right why not
open against this is something that
everybody wants fortnight was one of the
pioneers you have games like dauntless
now doing it you know gamers
want that online community scribes and
you know firsthand playing cop how long
that week so it says going for
competitor here legend account is like
30 minutes a match or something I heard
legend on comp is ridiculous yeah shout
the hybrid he says all I really want is
cross say that I would take cross for
now yes
I mean it yeah I don't know how much
they're storing on their back ends but
the majority of its already there
especially game history and stuff like
that's why you have a Bungie account and
and you had one I think starting it -
are you required to have one with T - I
think you've required but uh but yeah
either way I mean like all that player
from there yeah it lives in api's so
it's yeah I don't I don't know what that
takes but yeah I'm very excited just to
see I could play with my nephew like
yeah mine too my nephew's play on
PlayStation I could like be like hey you
guys what whisper all right come on my
xbox clan they're so mad when I let me
box got me over you know PC go back go
back
no but at least I can play with them you
don't say like if exact this is exciting
stuff I'm dying to know what the hell
they're what's the future what are they
what I'm thinking about so losing less
than a week now I mean literally like
Thursday next a lobby how do you go to
e3 I'm gonna be I'm gonna be right there
I am mine you're gonna find that one
somewhere yeah yeah hold that and go
hold that boom Mike Goss and be like
yeah so for one podcast we will see
barring your schedule if we can squeeze
in at least something about what drops
and honestly like we'll have the raid
and the two days later we're gonna have
this so sometime maybe Thursday
afternoon if you've got time we are
gonna try a new podcast in you get
something because we got to talk about
it because if they draw now the question
is do you guys think it will be
they'll drop a Vidak on Thursday and
then they talk more or do you think it's
like how do you guys think they're gonna
space these two because it's to within
five days of each other yeah it's very
interesting what good Keely and the like
helium is allergic apart yeah um he's
the 11th and their thing is the 5th 6th
6th Thursday I add Thursdays I think
Thursday is gonna be a flat-out
presentation like a brunette just yeah
whether that's of you know anything
related to a fight or not it's just
gonna be a flat-out here's the thing and
then Keeley's is probably gonna be a
little bit more in depth to just the
discussions of how this came to be what
happened up with the plant vision of
what did you guys learn all throughout
being with Microsoft and now with Sony
having laid in bed with both of these
major you know like what are you trying
to do I think it's gonna get into more
of like they're not necessarily destiny
even you know because they say the
future of Bungie and destiny - yes and
then going back and thinking of all of
that venture capital that they got for
another new IP that is not related to
destiny but I think we're gonna hear a
lot about just Bungie just flat-out
Bunji Bunji centipoise yeah you right
distinction is future of Bungie and
destiny - yeah maybe maybe they do talk
about that IP yeah all of that pretty
much some media is like I'm thinking
yeah I think I don't know if a viaduct
would be right they say tune in that's
gotta be a full stream that's gotta be a
stream where they talk about it they've
got some directors I want Luke on there
that's the one I want on Thursday
I want Luke in there if Luke is sitting
this deej I'm just gonna like melt in my
chair and I'm done oh it's gonna be
crazy that would be a make I don't know
if I've ever seen those two sit next to
each other ever actually because he's
usually in like his own box of a video
separate or he'll be in like he did like
one interview before when it was
whatever for you taking anything good go
ahead refer cut one second good point
though by Vagabond Oh Thursday
specifically says do
next chapter destiny though whereas the
Colosseum says Bungie future Bungie and
destitute that's not interesting thing
to what what happens this I'm excited
I'm dying to know what's going on like
what is this thing and whether they got
me we've been speculating what's gonna
come like Annual Pass expansion are we
waiting are we getting it soon are we
getting it later do you talk about d3 to
you what do you do when they say d2
right now so that's why they say very
specifics right I think that's probably
gonna be whatever the next year is but
which is still odd though considering
the press kit that we you know you've
got it to the when it came out with
season The Drifter they only put out
destiny logos there were no destiny to
logos in there I'll just straight out
destiny no and then again they on the
Blizzard launcher they removed the from
that so it's just partnered games now
and then what was the other thing there
was one more but of course I can't
remember a lot of bots interesting it's
just a lot of interesting stuff
interesting yeah yeah so Tuesday starts
some crazy
with the season lots of stuff going on
lots of content to play and then
Thursday Minds get exploded in a great
way with what is to come next so the
futures looking ever bright at least
because season opulence looks like it's
got fun raid potential you know some
variation of crafting and things like
that so many things to look forward to
and then we're a week away from now in
the future which is so much sooner than
I thought it was coming so yeah I'm I'm
just gonna be counting the days and the
hours that morning reading too much into
everything I go bad like Kosmos reply to
somebody on reddit maybe I'm stupid but
like where do we tune in and it was just
the word everywhere and I was like what
we're all talking about I mean
everywhere
yeah I was like YouTube so that work is
it like a buy dog right right like
mm-hmm
yeah so I think unless you guys have
anything else you guys want to talk
about Inc yeah it's like I know you're
probably getting tired but no well it's
been a lot of fun this morning I know
we've been talking a lot chad has been
great you guys are always amazing again
this will be out on audio
so check iTunes check Spotify check
those things I'll get the video up in a
couple places on iron Lords podcast and
then mine I get those up usually about a
day apart so all of those things will go
out there but thank you guys it's been a
ton of fun this morning but before we go
I want to let you NARAS wrap this thing
up tell people where they can find you
the best place to look for you and you
know what to expect
yeah she made perfect timing there with
her introduction yeah that was my cat
yeah yeah no you guys can find me on
well you can find anything related to me
and all of the infographics that I
provide for destiny at Nara Stevie and I
are is TV equally I'm on Twitter and
Instagram at mr. iris mr underscore
Navis NIR is and yeah can begin back and
some streaming stuff probably soon
otherwise just doing the normal stuff
cranking all graphics talking about
nerdy stuff and yeah thank you guys so
much for having me on today this is this
is a lot of fun I almost forgot actually
I almost forgot Russell so for our
guests we always have a question so we
got to know top three moments for you
and your destiny play time whether ever
news hit d1 was no it's just your top
three moments in destiny that you have
experienced okay top three you know I
gave him morning so he had a little time
yeah yeah one was and I can't remember
what quest this was for I just remember
because it was my first time and in the
vault of glass
what was the name I never rated in DD
one we had to get those little pieces
you had to fall underneath and then go
into that little Cameron part and it was
a piece of one of those effort black
spindle or not or was that something
else it was towards the latter half of
d1 d1 went down into the portal in vault
in the other direction that hidden quest
that people found that other portal I
know okay so anyways that was my first
taste of like mystery in destiny and and
granted so that was swords the latter
half but second is immediately the day
whisper came out I will never ever ever
ever forget it I was at work in the
middlee afternoon just sitting on
Twitter like I always do and I just see
this video from this guy that says yo
portal open up hit like and now I don't
know where to go anybody seen this
before I was like oh gotta go down gotta
go now and then and then probably just
beating my first braid ever
that would have been Globa then-- with
when it first came in on playstation
with with a great set of homies and an
individual - who brought me in and
taught me the ways and hasn't stopped
ever since so yeah and it really made
you know like that sense of community
had been that's what got me hearing and
and doing what I do today so absolutely
that's of those guys if there if any of
them are watching or no we gotta love
the communal aspect of a rage was gonna
say you pretty much encapsulated destiny
with your three right there you had
mystery the community the raids and just
like the secrets and stuff like all of
that stuff is are those special moments
and yeah you kind of nailed all of them
yeah way to have way to set the bar way
I had to get that one then I almost
forgot but I know I told it to you but
yeah well last that for every guest so
yeah
we do have a I'll give you guys a little
tease we'd ever guess coming on the 28th
of June so that one will be
as well so that question will get asked
again but yeah that's pretty much all I
got for today guys I didn't want to get
that one in so the next week is are
gonna be crazy stay tuned on Twitter on
my YouTube community feed just anywhere
we can as soon as we know like the
timing of our kind of whatever we can do
on Thursday it's gonna happen just
whenever we can kind of sit down and
knock it out so Thursday's gonna be nuts
we'll talk about the raid we'll talk
about whatever the reveal is that's
gonna be a whole thing in itself so yeah
honestly like that I'm looking forward
to and you guys know where to find me
it's Yvan says everywhere eb o and t is
YouTube twitch Twitter I barely have an
Instagram so doesn't really matter but I
also do have a patreon if you guys do
you want to support me directly that's
always appreciated so all those pieces
are out there and then kognito what do
you got your twig from me at will
kognito to youtube is I love podcasts
this Sunday is the conclusion of our
prediction series will come check it out
we had a last two weeks we did a Sony
and Nintendo and this week it is
Microsoft so you already heard what am i
sneak peek ha takes but I think I have
it there but uh yeah check that out man
I love podcast every Sunday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern we are gonna have an all-star
panel of some Xbox Microsoft royalty in
the building so I believe right now we
got a dealer gaming Tim dog Randall for
maybe just got no central fingers
crossed we'll see what happens but uh
you know check check us out man it
should be good it's one week before e3
so speculation is rampant high and yeah
man I'm excited man and of course you
already know the last word and we should
try to shoot for uh next week Thursday
and instead of hours day after this
thing I was no way yeah so it's like 10
o'clock central one o'clock for you
after that goes live and before you do
your stuff so mid-afternoon early early
evening whatever we can put that in just
stay tuned follow us on Twitter and you
guys will know or at least right here on
switch hit that follow in the
notification so when we go live then you
can check for it but it'll be Thursday
afternoon evening sometime when we jump
into this one because damn I don't even
know what to say himself yeah I'll be
flying out to LA next morning man joyous
you know thank you it's like the Super
Bowl a game and it you're busy you're
working hard and prepping but you you
once you get to settle and enjoy a
little bit you you really appreciate
yeah I'm definitely looking for the next
time do you eat because who knows what
are you gonna be able to talk about
right after this review yeah like the
menagerie and the raid already end in
that as well so can't say it's gonna be
a short one but we'll try and fit on
what we can absolutely yeah so that is
all we've got for episode 61 it is May
31st wrapping this Friday up for you
guys so thank you very much
and sonaris what we try and say at the
end we try and get it in sync is we just
say and I'll say and this is and I have
to like wait because we're all delayed
on timing we say the last word together
so I'm gonna say and and this is and
we'll try and say this all together and
wrap it up all right so thank you guys
for tuning in and this is the last word
yeah better than sometime